with a franchise based on double cross's
realistic face masks and all sorts of
world ending macguffins it's no shame to
be a bit confused while watching the
Mission Impossible movie here are the
moments that left us scratching our
heads and dead reckoning part One
spoilers ahead
Mission Impossible dead reckoning begins
aboard a Russian submarine patrolling
the Bering Sea in the first couple of
shots were introduced to both the entity
at the time a seemingly innocuous AI
housed in some sort of Mainframe aboard
the sub and the two-part key that
controls it an attack from a hostile sub
prompts a Russian crew to launch a
torpedo of their own but it all ends up
being a ruse there was no other sub
every reading on the Russians computers
was a fabrication of the AI which tricks
the crew into destroying themselves all
of that is pretty clear on the first
watch but lots of details are obfuscated
why is the AI there to begin with why
does it become aggressive and kill the
Russians as the story moves forward we
get a bit more context the AI was
apparently constructed by the United
States and was at some point moved to
the Russian sub to test its abilities
even if it was an ultra smart AI it
seems extraordinarily difficult to sneak
it aboard a high-tech stealth submarine
so why such a difficult task would be a
test run is a bit confusing what is made
clear by denlinger at the end of dead
reckoning is that the sub's destruction
was a rogue action for the
the U.S never intended for it to
actually attack the Russians
after the apparent death of ilsa Faust
dead reckoning shows us a top-secret
meeting of U.S intelligence officials
the topic is the escaped entity but
before a concrete decision can be made a
suspicious Intruder gases the whole room
and knocks out everyone except the
former IMF director Eugene kittridge as
the assailant removes his disguise we
see that it's actually Ethan Hunt unless
you're paying close attention this
confrontation might be a bit confusing
both men seem to want the same thing and
Ethan remains dedicated to the mission
that kittridge assigned him he's upset
because he's realized that getridge is
the one who put out a bounty on ilsa
something that wasn't disclosed in the
mission briefing this was done in an
effort to flush her out and obtain her
half of the key as quickly as possible
Ethan is understandably angry about this
but since she's actually still alive at
least part of his rage is a ruse the
Schism with kittridge only grows because
the director wants a key turned over to
the US government Ethan insists that
even his own superiors can't be trusted
with the entity saying that it must
instead be destroyed this is the
fundamental split that sends him Rogue
for the rest of the movie The
prioritization of the greater good over
the demands of his country given what's
revealed about denlinger later on it
seems Ethan made the right call
Ethan and the gang's first real Face-Off
with the entity comes at the airport in
Abu Dhabi where the mission to track the
key buyer is disrupted by a nuclear bomb
sort of as Ethan evades government
agents and tries to track down the buyer
then she discovers a strange bag in the
airport security system that sure enough
contains what appears to be a nuclear
explosive what's even more unnerving is
that it seems to know who Benji is
revealing its Cipher with the phrase you
are done Benji's last name spelled out
it also asks a series of personal
questions and knows when Benji isn't
telling the truth in the end the bomb
turns out to be a dud so what was the
point for one it was probably partly
sent to distract Ethan's team from the
real issue Grace Gabriel and the
acquisition of the key but also it seems
like the entity is just showing off it
knows exactly which team member will
come to disarm the device and knows all
of his personal secrets The Entity
lingers in the background during most of
the movie but this is one of the few
moments when we see just how prideful
and devious it can be
perhaps the biggest unanswered question
in dead reckoning is how the keys to the
entity get out of the ice in the pairing
sea nobody besides Gabriel and denlinger
seem to know where the lock to the ai's
source code is but since both halves of
the key were retrieved from the
submarine's crash site that doesn't
really make sense if you knew where to
look for the keys and you knew why they
were important you also probably would
have known how important the submarine
is if the keys were retrieved by the
Russian government they probably would
have gone right down to the sub to
access the Mainframe if it was the U.S
government that got them out of the
water then Ethan's whole mission never
would have happened so who did get them
out we know ilsa got hers by stealing
them from someone else but how did they
get the key unfortunately this is one of
the confusing moments in dead reckoning
that can't be fully explained it's
possible that part 2 of the Mission
Impossible movie will illuminate what
actually happened to the keys but for
now we're left to our own devices
more a series of moments in just one The
Entity pulls lots of strings from the
Shadows throughout dead reckoning a lot
of these manipulations aren't revealed
until after the fact though making some
moments pretty confusing for starters at
least part of ilsa's Mission to acquire
the key seems to have been orchestrated
by The Entity she believed that she was
being contacted by agents within MI6 and
since she was no longer a proper member
of the group she didn't think twice
about using indirect communication it's
implied that the entity used her to
require half of the key knowing she'd be
able to get the job done that brought
the device into play making it easier
for Gabriel and his team to steal it
back it's also possible that the entity
wanted ilsa so that Ethan would get
pulled in as it seems to have a sadistic
interest in him just like Gabriel his
fate is Britain shall we write yours too
it's also implied that Grace might have
been hired by The Entity to Rob Ethan at
the Abu Dhabi airport she says her
contact with her employer was almost
entirely digital the White Widow later
takes credit for hiring Grace but since
the entity seems to know every one of
the Widow's moves it could still have
been working through her without her
knowledge after all Grace's resemblance
to both Maria and ilsa is striking so
she could have been chosen just to mess
with Ethan's head
one of the most confusing moments in
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part 1
is the fragmented flashback that shows
Ethan's dark past with Gabriel in the
shadowy scene we see a young Gabriel
shoot a woman dead a woman who's later
identified as Marie apparently she was
Ethan's love before he joined the IMF
while not expressly stated it's implied
that Ethan took the fall for her murder
and was sentenced to time in prison
while there he was given the option to
go free and join the IMF this is a
pretty huge Revelation especially since
neither Gabriel nor Marie have ever been
mentioned in the prior six movies what's
less clear is why Gabriel would have
killed Marie in the first place he then
says that he enjoys causing suffering
which suggests that Marie's death was
more than just a random act of violence
was Gabriel involved in global terrorism
all the way back then even before Ethan
was in the IMF and why was Ethan so
convinced that he was dead who is he
someone I should have killed a long time
ago the answers to these questions will
hopefully come in dead reckoning part
two maybe Gabriel's original
relationship with Ethan had something to
do with the early development of the AI
until we learn more about what the
villain actually wants the answers will
continue to elude us
the first half of Mission Impossible
dead reckoning part 1 culminates in a
massive dance party in Venice hosted by
the White Widow but secretly controlled
by Gabriel and the entity it's a
convoluted sequence with a ton of moving
Parts making it easy to miss some things
on your first time through here's the
deal the White Widow hired Grace to
steal the key in Abu Dhabi telling her
to deliver the goods to the party in
Venice later on Grace does as she's told
without ever knowing who actually hired
her but before the Widow can find her at
the party she's intercepted by Gabriel
he too wants the key and tells her that
she will likely die if she doesn't hand
it over to him but before he can get too
threatening the Widow appears creating a
sort of Mexican standoff to protect the
key and herself Grace stashes it in the
pocket of the white widow's brother Zola
without him noticing then Ethan and ilsa
show up in the whole Motley Crew steps
into a more private area to chat the
Widow claims that she hasn't decided yet
who to sell the key to but Gabriel knows
that's a lie beforeetells her trip the
next day on the Orient Express where she
plans to sell the key to the US
government in a shocking twist it's
revealed that all of the music visual
advisors at the party are in fact The
Entity and that the whole situation has
been orchestrated by the AI because of
this the White Widow lets Gabriel walk
away unscathed and Ethan Grace and ilsa
have to fend for themselves
ilsophiles this killed off in a big
surprise twist Midway through Mission
Impossible dead reckoning part 1. sadly
being a series Mainstay for almost a
decade can't save her from getting
sacrificed to motivate Ethan at least
she gives her life so that Grace may
live though right for whatever reason
Gabriel is determined to kill only one
of the two women even after his plan to
make Ethan's shoes falls apart he knows
the best way to get to me the whole one
will die thing is just another way to
torment Ethan showing him that the
entity is in full control and that he is
powerless but that doesn't explain why
Gabriel still wouldn't capture Grace
after killing ilsa sure he may not want
them both dead but Grace has crucial
information and skills that prove
necessary for Ethan's Mission shouldn't
he take her with him to wrap up the
loose end it's implied that Grace hides
during ilsa and Gabriel's fight which is
why he lets her go when Ethan finds
Elsa's body on the bridge Gabriel is
gone and Grace quickly jumps out of her
hiding spot was Gabriel really unable to
find her even with the entity's help
this inconsistency can be explained Away
by saying that everything is part of the
ai's plan but that's not really a sound
that's why an answer
Ethan and the crew develop a foolproof
plan to sneak aboard the Orient Express
and swipe the key from the White Widow
that is until the mask machine breaks
initially Ethan plans to go undercover
alongside Grace disguising himself as
the Widow's brother Zola but because the
machine breaks down they're left with
only the one mask and Ethan has to
figure out a different way to get onto
the train in the moment this predicament
feels too uncomfortable to be a mistake
surely someone sabotaged The Mask
machine in order to keep Ethan off the
train if you were waiting for the other
shoe to drop on who actually disabled
the machine you may have been
disappointed by the ending it seems that
the whole thing was simply an instance
of failed technology as no other
explanation is given that said it's
pretty consistent with previous Mission
Impossible movies where technology
usually fails at the most exciting
moment naturally It All Leads up to
making Tom Cruise do another extremely
dangerous stunt to keep things moving is
it worth it sure but in a story with an
All-Seeing AI enemy you know high-tech
machine breaking down at a pivotal
moment seems more meaningful than it
actually ends up being
director of denlinger doesn't seem all
that important for most of Mission
Impossible dead reckoning part 1. he
only really features in one major scene
before the end in which he appears
totally oblivious about the entity and
the threat that it poses but in the
Final Act we learned that denlinger's
apparent ignorance is all in elaborate
ruse like kittridge denlingerboards the
Orient Express in an effort to acquire
the key from the White Widow he stays in
his cabin while kittridge does the deal
but he doesn't expect Gabriel and his
crew to attack the way they do facing
down the Techno terrorist denlinger
spills the beans revealing himself to be
a truly vile person in a monologue that
ends as abruptly as it begins denlinger
gets so little screen time and dies so
quickly that his whole scheme might blow
right by you here's a gist he's a techno
fascist who wants to overthrow and
control the US government and use the
American Military to take over the world
all he says he needs to make it happen
is full control of the entity which he
plans to use to turn public sentiment in
his favor and disrupt any would-be
adversaries National coups and world
domination might seem like pretty big
Ambitions for a man with so few lines
but denlinger is full of surprises in
fact he's such a twisty character that
some viewers might wonder if he actually
survives
spy Thrillers are always full of double
crosses and Rogue agents but by the end
of Mission Impossible dead reckoning
part 1 it's downright tough to know
who's on whose side this is particularly
perplexing in the case of Ethan
kittridge and the IMF your days of
fighting for the so-called greater good
are over get rich boards the Orient
Express is a representative of the US
government and if he had walked off the
train with a key it would likely have
gone right into denlinger's pocket sure
the former IMF director might not know
that his boss is secretly planning a
world takeover but he must have some
inclination that what he's doing is
dangerous Ethan knows that too yet he
still tells Grace that kittridge will
protect her to make matters even more
confusing the final shots of the film
are accompanied by closing narration
from kittridge who addresses Ethan
directly and seems to approve his Rogue
Mission the best way to understand all
these shifting Dynamics is by
remembering what the IMF is yes it's a
government agency but its top secret
nature demands operating outside the
rules more often than not kittridge is
not even the director of the agency
anymore but like Ethan he's playing two
different games no official intelligence
agency would approve what he and Ethan
really want to do making the IMF itself
sort of a rogue entity by nature is that
a sustainable model probably not but
it's worked for seven movies
in his final monologue director
denlinger briefly explains the actual
origins of the entity which up to that
point are kept a mystery he breezes
through the origin story so quickly
though that you might miss it if you
blink plus some of the biggest questions
surrounding the AI aren't answered by
his explanation what denlinger seems to
say is that the entity was created by
the United States as a much more docile
system it was through some unclear
series of events planted on the Russian
submarine seen at the beginning of the
movie The Goal according to denlinger
was a kind of test run those who created
the AI wanted to see if it could
effectively disrupt the sub-stealth
systems of course it ended up doing far
more than that destroying the sub
through trickery and Vanishing into the
digital night denlinger claims that the
entity evolved while away on its Mission
transforming into the more conniving
intelligence that we see in the movie
that suggests that the US never meant
for it to be a full information control
machine but rather simply an anti-spy
tool of course none of that explains the
keys how the AI got onto the sub and why
it needed to destroy it those are
questions that only dead reckoning part
2 can answer
Gabriel is an enigma by Design from his
Biblical name to the cryptic way he
speaks he's meant to come across as
mysterious mythical and terrifying his
history with Ethan explains her personal
Feud but we never actually get an
explanation of why he's Allied himself
with the entity his true motivations and
desires are unknown but thanks to some
Clues we can theorize a bit you have no
idea the power I represent Ethan says
that he thought Gabriel had died years
before that means that he hasn't been a
high-profile Terrorist on a global scene
until recently there isn't much time
between the entity's escape and
Gabriel's emergence which is also Highly
Questionable how is he so ready and
devoted with such a short amount of time
to prepare was the AI communing with
them before it escaped from the Russians
was it prepping him in the shadows for
what was to come it seems likely that
still doesn't answer the question of
what Gabriel actually wants though why
would he join forces with an AI that
presumably wants to take over and
subjugate the world Ethan says that he
sees death as a gift he wants to share
with the rest of the world and his
motivations could be as simple as that
but because he and Ethan share a pass
there must be more going on than Gabriel
simply being a Madman
[Music]